damián a reyes ha vuelto al trabajo pero
su mente a menudo deriva hacia su padre
quien sucumbió al coronavirus a los 76
años vivían juntos en queens un distrito
de nueva york' y es justamente allí
donde se encuentra el barrio que
registró el mayor número de casos y
muertes por kobe 19 en la ciudad hombre
resulta casi irónico corona en ese
vecindario muchos que conozco lo
tuvieron al menos 10 personas en mi
calle contando a mi padre a mi madre en
esa zona mayoritariamente hispana y de
bajos ingresos un 51% de las personas
sometidas a pruebas de anticuerpos
dieron positivo una tasa muy por encima
de la media de la gran manzana y el
virus sigue dejando huellas en el barrio
aquí las filas para obtener comida
gratis se hacen más largas día tras día
en su mayoría hombres latinos que
perdieron sus trabajos esta próxima
lucha todos los días para nuestra
comunidad en la zona y lo único que
podemos hacer en este momento para
ayudar es darles algo de comida
si bien tal es la realidad en los
barrios menos favorecidos en los más
acomodados las tasas son muy inferiores
el permanente abuso
la permanente agresión racismo y
discriminación de esta administración
hacia la comunidad inmigrante y
especialmente latina yo creo que le hizo
mucho más vulnerable y le hace mucho más
vulnerable sin embargo las elevadas
cifras de cero prevalencia en algunos
vecindarios de la ciudad es decir la
manifestación de presencia del virus
apuntan a que buena parte de su
población ya habría pasado la enfermedad
lo que podría ayudar a controlar una
segunda oleada